I didn't go Annie did you see the New
Avengers movie over the weekend yeah I
did I'm maybe it was a hype I mean I
thought it was it was good but it wasn't
great you know huh that's weird cuz I've
been looking online and talking people
most people absolutely loved it I know
but I used three hours long and I think
it could have been two and a half and
also I don't love movies with subtitles
so I I wasn't really
wait a minute avengers endgame doesn't
have subtitles well of course it does I
mean most people don't know Swedish so
it needs subtitles Annie what do you
what are you talking about Avengers
endgame is not in Swedish yes it is and
it's pronounced Avengers and game NER
we're talking about the same Avengers
end game yes Avengers and game the
swedish romantic comedy about two IKEA
managers who have nothing in common
except a fondness for each other
Avengers end game wait a minute where
did where the hell did what Adele did
you see that movie at the homonym on
Wilshire Oh
I thought you had that picture as proof
ready Andy no that's not the movie I was
talking about that that's not what
anybody is talking about who says hey
that's was hurtful yeah that was very
hurtful I'm sorry are you are you the
people from the poster yes
I'm Avengers and I'm game and hey crowd
if you can't get into Avengers end game
check out the vengers in the game right
there home and I'm on Wilshire
roll the clip Billy huh
fun fun you're saying it will get
humorous dismiss first ad wait a minute
that was the Infinity Gauntlet
no that's discarded chin it's the myth
we use to remove hot meatballs from the
oven
of course okay great
so check out Avengers and game it's good
you